I remember when I was training
um for for my first Ultraman was pretty
fit in my own mind hired a coach
literally for the first year I don't
think I did a single workout that was
above zone two I was able to go from
somebody who couldn't run faster than 10
minutes per mile without going into zone
three to two years later being able to
run like seven fifteens in my zone too
and it's all about the ability to come
back the next day
and the next day and the next day and I
think there's something about that
consistency such that when you develop
that robustness and you do have an
effort let's say you're attacking a hill
or whatever and you're way out of your
Zone too to do so you come back down to
that Baseline Zone too very quickly as
opposed to like you know being winded
for an extended period of time and kind
of losing Pace as a result